[Music] The
café caught fire because of Aso Prefecture The
pen that Hanako passed has already been collected.
If you find the secret,
then use it as a card to gain an advantage.
It didn't turn out to be a card for
Bolivia ah ah
I can smell the spicy scent between my arms and boobs
I'm tan but I thought I was saying it for the sake of
the
teacher
[music]
Agria
It's okay now The Ministry of the Environment
Considering the odor index regulatory guidelines that have been announced,
if it's okay to leave it alone, it's a number, so
it's totally fine.
The people in the 8th grade insist that it's made to mix well with that smell, and
there are parents and children who love that kind of
smell.
People are also
tan